I've got Allen calling in from Georgia
Allen how are you I'm doing great how
are you Chris oh yeah buddy I'm focused
and not finished what's on your mind hey
you guys are can generalise hope you can
help me well I hope so I have I had
about eighty seven thousand dollars in
student loan debt
and prior to August my plan for having
that paid off was in the entire bucket
of public service loan forgiveness
I found out around that time that only
about 2/3 of that so about 60,000
applied for that program and 30,000 of
it bitten so that started our sort of
gazelle intense towards that 30 grand
we've been really doing a great job of
paying that off okay however I still
have a little bit of fees that wants to
still stay in that mode of maybe I could
receive that funding for the other 60
grand I and so I'm starting starting to
look out at some of the percentage rates
on getting potentially refinancing for
for your for your calculation my average
interest payment is about 6.8% for my
loans and I could refinance to around
three and a half or 3.75 so I'm thinking
I don't think it would be worth
refinancing for just the 30 but 30,000
but if I were to give up on the dream of
public service loan forgiveness then I
could refinance and make it work and I
wanted your advice on what what you
would do if you were in my shoes yeah
Alan tell me this what's your household
income about 90,000 before tax
okay 90,000 before taxes and you owe
87,000 and the student loan debt correct
yes is that the only debt you owe one
yes sir okay so the house of you do you
have a home yet we rent you rent okay so
look at this hey Alan I'm gonna be
honest with you I've read through some
of these loan forgiveness programs and
here's the thing that makes me
apprehensive about believing them they
typically if you read in the little laws
or the little bylaws or the little
requirements it talks about in there
that that which things that can never
happen meaning you can never be late on
a payment if you're late on
then it for Fitzhugh from the program
all right
they also most the time will reserve the
right to change the program I don't
trust it now I've heard of some people
that have done it there's teachers and
or firefighters or things that nature
that have qualified but it's one of
those things where I go do I really
trust them to keep the program around or
to not change something in the next six
seven years as you're trying to approach
it now I don't want you to think I'm
being negative Nancy because I'm not I'm
just saying the likelihood right I mean
it means you could send in a payment and
it get there on time but they don't post
it on time right or they and so then
what so I think you're better off with
you having the mindset of it could or it
couldn't I want I'd rather you being
controlled and you be at their mercy if
that makes sense right now that's the
$60,000 swing I know you're thinking
okay little bald man okay this is
$60,000 Chris and and and yeah I'm gonna
follow it to a tee I would just say read
over the doctor program guidelines very
clearly look at it call them with any
questions and just have your thing down
to a tee but I would also say this you
need a back-up plan if they change the
game on you and they've been known to do
that a few times and so Alan I would
much rather you be in control and you
say you know what we're gonna handle
this and we're looking at this we're
gonna get ourselves free and so I've
told people hey be saving it up put that
money aside and lo and behold if they
change the program you've got money that
you can grab and just say I'm done with
this and so it's just a mindset I want
you to be prepared I have too many times
I've heard of people that have waited on
that forgiveness program only for the
program to be adjusted or changed and it
just leads the heartache and headache I
say attack the debt get it out of your
life and move forward thank you for your
call my friend